our next speaker is a successful PhD
economics PhD
Dropout one of his favorite hobbies is
convincing other people not to get a
PhD so if you're thinking about getting
one please go up to him at deposit booth
and say hey I'm think about getting a
PhD and let him have a chat with you
everyone please welcome Alex um
seriously I will do my best to convince
you so if you're thinking about it just
talk to me um I'm here uh again this
year to uh try and convince you to care
about boring operational stuff so I'm
gonna spend the next 20 minutes to teach
you to learn to love logging um if you
want this presentation it's not that
interesting presentation but if you want
it it's on my website Alex
K.P uh so you can uh you can find it
there um just a little about me um I
lead the solutions engineering team at
posit uh formerly our studio and uh what
what my team does we help our customers
get sort of installed up and running
deployed configured with posits pro
products and so part of that often is
helping those people think about how do
they take an app that they've developed
locally theyel on their desktop and get
it out and share it how do they get
things into into production um and so
one of the things that we think about is
is this this person particularly like
being on the other end of the phone from
this person who's yelling at you because
like the shiny app is down or like
they're looking your plots and the
numbers are wrong or you know the the
the dashboard isn't working for me I I
hit the slider and everything crashed
and like I think we've probably mostly
all been in in that moment and that sort
of moment moment of horror um and the
reality is that like this kind of
failure is is sort of inevitable right
you you want to have good practices
around testing your code around Version
Control around uh you know uh
controlling what goes into it good um uh
uh uh pipelines uh and that sort of
thing but but this kind of thing is is
going to happen right and so the point
of logging which is again what I'm going
to try and convince you to care about is
that uh logging is not really about
avoiding failure although it can help
while you're while you're developing an
app what it's really about is it's about
letting you figure out what happened
after a failure it's about sort of
forensic analysis of being able to go
back and be like oh I understand why
this happens like when the when the dude
is yelling at you on the phone you can
be like no I don't know what's wrong but
I know I can figure it out that's that's
really what the the important thing is
in in that moment so a little bit about
logging particularly for for data
science if if you were not at a data
science conference we were at like a
JavaScript conference that's like a webd
conference and we were talking about
logging right we'd mostly be talking
about operational characteristics we be
talking about things like you know does
the button do what we want the button to
do do do results return turn in a sort
of reasonable amount of time does the
app crash when when you try and use it
right that's what sort of normal logging
is about as a data scientist you
actually you have to care about that
we'll get to that in a minute but you
actually have another level that you
have to care about which is correctness
right you have to care are the numbers
that are showing up correct and
fundamentally because so much of data
science is about discovering new things
and learning things and and going into
Uncharted Territory like you're not
going to have something to to check your
correctness against there isn't a given
answer that you can just check oh yeah I
got the right answer and so so much of
logging for correctness purposes uh
really means doing process checks right
does the process work the way I think it
does and so I'm going to introduce uh a
spicy take here uh which is that you
should always use literate programming
always full like full stop see Little D
up there giving me give me a a fist I
love it right always use lit program so
what what is literate programming
literate programming uh is a term coined
by Donald n uh he's uh very very famous
computer scientist won the Turing prize
like the Nobel Prize of computer science
um so like this is not just me saying
this uh and and he coined this term
called literate programming uh which is
interspersing code pros and output in
one one thing right and of course like
we are here at an our conference so you
all are going like of course I know
we're talking about like our markdown
we're talking about quto we're talking
about
right and so this is this is sort of my
my you know uh uh uh encouragement is
that like this is the way right we
should not be writing our scripts and
doing things we care about in them
because once you've done them poof it's
gone forever right you get no evidence
of what just happened if you do it in a
literate programming format right if
you're running just a job and you run it
in a liter literate programming format
you do a smart thing of like printing
some useful things into the console and
it gets messed up later you can
reconstruct what what happened and
that's really useful so like you know
the way the way a project might look if
you're doing this right is like you have
your directory with your project you
have the like document you actually care
about as a as a quto or an R markdown
that's fine not. R uh and then you have
your your functions documented with with
roxygen just like if you were doing it
for a uh a targets Pipeline and and you
have your your test that uh you know
stuff as well that you should you should
throw in there so uh that's that's sort
of big picture right just do the job in
a literate programming format because
then you get to keep the output and you
can also put some you know comments
about like oh this should look like this
and if it doesn't that's a that's a good
hint um a couple thoughts on what you
should log into those literate
programming formats um one thing I'll
recommend is the point blank package if
you've never used it before it's a
really cool package helps you create
sort of a data validation workflow I'm
not going to spend a lot but it's like
really cool uh strong recommend you can
have it there's a lot of automated stuff
it can do to to validate that your data
is what you think it is and you can also
sort of build your own validators quite
quite easily it's a very cool package um
and uh can work in a lot of different
kind of pipeline mechanisms um there are
two things in particular I'm going to
encourage you to log into that literate
programming format whatever whatever
you're using the first is your joins and
I know this is really
like have used sta St joins are amazing
because it gives you statistics on how
many records joined and how many didn't
and and how that works and so you know
but you can do this yourself right you
can like do the math if you go to join
two data sets you can look at how many
unique IDs are in data set one you can
look at how many unique IDs are in data
set two and you should have an
expectation before you do that joint of
exactly how many rows are going to
be right you should it's not like
there's no magic there right you could
say like oh there are this many unique
IDs here they match uniquely to this
data set we should have a one to one
match or I know there aren't they're
going to be duplicates I should have
some sense of of how many so ideally do
the math and just figure out how many
there should be now that that is a pain
in the butt I'm not gonna lie so like I
usually don't do the math but what you
can at least do is you can document in
your in your uh uh in your literate
programming format right how many rows
did I start out with in each data set
and how many rows did I end up with in
the join data set because that gives you
some really good uh uh information if
you look back later right very often
you're expecting your joints to be
unique so you have you know a thousand
rows over here 10,000 rows over here and
you're expecting a thousand and you end
up with a thousand and10 that's usually
a really good hint that something weird
has happened so at least document how
many rows are in the sort of uh
resulting data set and the other thing
you can do is look for duplicate IDs
right if you're if you're expecting that
data set should join uniquely just just
check are there any duplicate IDs right
these are really easy checks that if you
throw
into that script all of a sudden you you
you know and you go back later you go oh
there were a bunch of duplicate IDs here
and I expected none that's a really
powerful
signal the other uh thing that I uh
always check as a matter of course is
recodes and what I mean by that is like
when you have you know a certain number
of categorical variables and you're you
know taking months and making them
quarters when you're taking the entire
rainbow and making it I don't know how
you spill up a rainbow but like three
chunks of a rainbow right um or or a
numeric values and chunky right um the
the simplest thing you do is just cross
tab your values before and after right
and do they look the way you think they
should look um it's again very simple
thing to check but I I can't tell you
how many uh times this has saved my butt
to just dump this into my my quto
document um and also especially any that
don't recode at all right that's a
really good signal especially if you're
running a job over time right you get
new data in and like somebody's going to
secretly add a new value that you don't
expect to that variable being able to
catch that um is is is really important
and can really sort of uh you know save
the day later on or at least help you
reconstruct what what happened um one
other category that I honestly don't
have a lot to say about but you should
pay attention to is machine learning
models if you've got a machine learning
model you're running it on new data you
got to check your model drift and
quality there are a ton of proprietary
Frameworks to do this I if you want an
open source framework V is great um it
is particularly great for sort of
relatively small collections of
experiments if you're running hundreds
or thousands of machine learning modelss
in production V which is which is a sort
of model Ops uh R RN python package that
lets you deploy version monitor machine
learning models it's great sort of if
you're at a relatively modest scale but
if you're doing hundreds or thousands
you're going to have a proprietary
solution to do this cool so that that's
those are some thoughts on on logging
for like data science purposes now let's
talk about like logging for logging sake
and and and I mean this in terms of the
operational qualities right does the uh
does the app run in a reasonable amount
of time does it crash those sorts of
things um and so the the you know what
what a lot of people do here is they
just print you just print stuff right
that that works it's it's not bad and so
what I want to talk about is just that
you can up your game to do better with
like very little additional work like
that's that's what I'm going to try and
convince you so there's a great package
called log for R um it's inspired by a
package called log for JS which is a big
JavaScript logging package it's
maintained by my colleague Aon Jacobs at
at posit um and it's it's just a really
elegant sort of logging framework that
makes it super easy to add logging to a
script that you otherwise other
otherwise might just dump print print
statements into now there is a little
bit of a mental model to have around
logging it's it's not hard but when
you're logging using a logging framework
you don't just print a statement instead
what you do is you give a logging level
right so logging comes these are the
ones that um log for our uses different
pack packages have different levels
right there are five levels and they
sort of
go up down that's hard to in terms of
level of severity right so they go from
debug to fatal right and so debug is the
kind of thing that like just you care
about it's like oh right did the thing
run correctly right it's like function
internals you're gonna log as debug
statements all the way up to fatal right
like app is crashing here are my parting
messages to the world Goodbye cruel
world like that's that's fatal right um
and so what you can do is you can you
can in your code and I'll show you this
in just a sec you declare this statement
that I'm making is this level of
severity and then when you're running
your code right you can provide usually
as an in an environment variable what
level do I want this time to log at so
when you're when you're developing
locally you could run it all the way on
debug mode so every little bit of of
documentation prints into your console
and then when you're running it in
production you probably want to choose
something a little more severe so that
not every little bit of information gets
gets dumped into uh into your console
so um actually I'm going to stick with
yeah okay so I'm going to talk about a
little bit of code here does this have a
no I don't know what that button does uh
I thought maybe it was a a laser pointer
but it's
not there is one on here is it this it's
that great okay we've got a laser
pointer okay so this is some code that
it's a shiny app that includes some
logging and so it's it's really easy to
add this login code to your app right
the main thing you need to add relative
to just some print statements is up at
the top you've got this little can
people see the laser pointer is that
visible sweet okay you've got this
little like I am instantiating a log
great I've instantiated a log that's G
to remain throughout my session it's
going to print stuff out and then I can
I just have these log statements so the
in for log for R it does this with the
function names right you could think of
it right like you could alternatively
design this package have taken arguments
but these are actually the function
names so you have log for our info you
provide the log object and then this is
just like what is going into the log I
have another info what's going into the
log uh here I have a try catch block and
if an error happens I dump a lot of
stuff into the log right and that's
that's generally a good practice because
again a huge point of the the the
logging here is forensics right is later
on we want to be able to come back and
forensically examine um what might have
happened that was bad so um I'm going to
show you
this looks like the Wi-Fi is not being
my friend so I'm going to just do it
live here we go can we see my studio yes
we can
Okay so let's run this app I'm going to
clear off my console
here run this app okay this is this is a
little shiny app uh this is taking the
Palmer Penguins data set uh which is
just a data set of like information
about penguins and uh it's it's letting
me it has some selectors here right I
can select a minimum Bill length I can
select sex and species and it computes
just the average mass of the Penguins in
that in that little uh
um you know subset of the data and you
can see down here right I got my app
started told me that and it told me the
the uh you know that I hit the compute
button because I said it to do that so
you know oh computation requested cool
now when let's say let's say I uh I do
something that I I intentionally Design
This to crash but like uh oh crashed my
app right and what you can see is that
then that TR catch block got invoked and
I get all of this stuff dumped out right
and I get dumped out here
a little
bigger the values that I input here that
yielded a bad outcome right and I could
do some digging like why did this cause
a bad outcome it turns out there are no
penguins with a a bill length of 60 or
more so this is trying to compute an
average on a set of size zero which
doesn't work right so this this now I I
had the information now to know well I
got a not a number error right that's a
big hint and then I can actually like go
in and forensic my way around around
these actual values um which can be a
really helpful way to um to to be able
to do this the the other thing I'll
point out right is that relative to just
printing print statements where you have
to with a print statement you gotta like
get in there every single little bit of
information has to go into the actual
print statement right uh that's
different here because the L this is all
Auto appended by the log right it's
giving me the info it's G telling me
that this is an info and it's giving me
a Tim stamp here and you can add other
things um
when I when you invoked the logger at
the top right uh this invoking the
logger you can add more stuff right you
can give it a custom format that prints
a ton of information in there including
like session information User
information all kinds of great stuff
that then you get for free uh in each
line of of the log um and I'm GNA switch
back to my
presentation there we
go we going to close our studio
yes don't save never save your workspace
image never save your workspace image um
okay other things that you can do that
are are useful um is what you saw there
is it with loging to the console right
it was just going to my R console that's
useful um because then uh I I can print
it out if you're on posit connect it
just goes right into the logs that you
get there on on connect which is nice um
but there are other places you might
want to log for example you might want
to go to the CIS log this is very common
when you're using Docker um that a lot
of dockerized deployments are the the
log you set up logging so that it's the
CIS log that sort of gets sucked out of
the container um or if your organization
has a logging framework that they use a
log aggregate something like Splunk or
data dog or some of these things very
often you're going to ship those logs
right off to uh to an HTTP um location
there there is also a file appender so
you can also put things in a file many
logging systems just like watch a
file the other option here is to
structured logging again if you're
shipping it off to to another um uh
system oh excuse me um that's a nice way
to be able to do it usually that would
be a Json blob and you just sort of put
the log in there and then you have other
systems that would consume that Json
blob and do something with it um cool uh
so that's that's what I have to say
about logging so as a data scientist you
unfortunately have to care about two
kinds of logging I am sorry you have to
care about operational logging I
recommend using log for R you got a very
brief tour through using it as you can
tell that did not take very long it's
like very simple to use it's barely more
complicated than print statements but it
gives you a much richer set of
information a much richer configuration
uh to be able to use and then you have
to check for correctness um which of
course is the uh the task of of literate
programming um I will uh if you thought
this was even moderately interesting
I'll take moderately um this is a book
that I'm working on called devops for
data science it is available at do4
ds.com uh it will the manuscript will be
final up here like this week or next
week which I'm so
excited thank you yes so pumped um there
will be print copies at some point but
it will be available online forever so
uh if if you're interested the first
whole section of this book is about
things this is chapter four logging up
there right uh uh there there's a lot of
stuff in here that's sort of advice for
data scientists to make your apps and
and projects more sort of like uh
welcoming from a devops perspective make
them work more smoothly things like
logging all stuff around cicd
deployments package management all that
kind of like stuff that I love and
people think is boring but they're wrong
super cool uh then the the the rest of
the book is really about sort of it
stuff so there's some stuff about how to
set up servers how to use Docker um and
then some stuff at the end on why if you
work at a big organization they probably
aren't going to be very happy with you
doing this yourself and how you can
maybe work with Enterprise it admin
folks to to make this work better um I
do since I'm here at the Lander
conference I want to give a special
shout out to Gus
Lipkin employee was one of the first
readers of this book and gave me a bunch
of really useful feedback so thank you
Gus up there in the
back it's way better than when he read
it so it was bad then um anyway thanks
for thanks for tuning in and uh yeah go
log some stuff thanks ready